[Musik]
lembeck
wir sind unterwegs mit der luftwaffe an
der ostflanke der nato f 18 kampfjets
und auch eurofighter patroullieren hier
unter anderem überwachen den luftraum
auch an der grenze zum kriegsgebiet
den treibstoff für die mission liefert
vor allem deutschland in der luft mit
dem a400m der jetzt fast täglich
unterwegs ist seit putins angriff auf
die ukraine
beitrag zur erhöhung der präsenz sehr
wichtig um die reaktionsfähigkeit und
abschreckungsfähigkeit der allianz zu
erhöhen
sagt der kommandant der tag für ihn und
seine kameraden beginnt früh um 5 uhr 30
startet das vorbereiten
nach dem briefing aufs rollfeld gleich
kann es losgehen in wulmstorf
niedersachsen
pünktlich um 8 uhr
[Musik]
ziel heute ostpolen nach eineinhalb
stunden flug der erste kontakt zwei
deutsche eurofighter brauchen treibstoff
ist beginnt der heikelste tank der
einsätze kerosin wechselt den besitzer
bei tempo 700 und 8000 meter über der
erde
[Musik]
wir haben aus den kameras dabei können
wir den gesamten tankvorgang beobachten
und haben somit die möglichkeit jeden
einzelnen schritt der ist betanken
vorgangs zu überprüfen die betankung
mission der luftwaffe sind extrem
wichtig denn seit putins blutigen
überfall auf die ukraine hat die nato
mehr als 30 flugzeuge an der ostflanke
in der luft und das permanent tag und
nacht
insgesamt sechs kampfjets versorgt die
luftwaffen crew an diesem tag 2 aus
spanien 4 aus deutschland mehr als 80
solcher einsätze gab es schon seit dem
beginn des krieges
man denkt ganz glaube die situation nach
die sich im moment darstellt die
grundsätzlich
beunruhigend ist aus meiner sicht der
raus muss ich sagen
die ich nicht mit einem anderen gefühl
an die fliegerei heran letztendlich wir
sind alle sehr gut ausgebildet wir haben
sind sehr lange ausgebildet wir wissen
was wir tun aber natürlich ist die
gesamte situation immer im hinterkopf
dabei die gefühle sind natürlich anders
da aber dafür sind wir halt ausgebildet
wir haben unsere ausbildung das egal was
passieren würde
wir wissen wie wir handeln sollten
für heute geht es zurück nach hause da
wartet sofort der tankwagen einmal voll
machen für den nächsten einsatz an der
ostgrenze der nacht
[Musik]